-Welcome, welcome,
welcome, welcome to
"The Tonight Show," everybody.
You're here, you made it.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Thank you for watching.
Well, let's get to
some news here, guys.
This morning,
the world's richest man,
Elon Musk, was named "Time"
magazine's Person of the Year.
Yeah.
Musk received the honor
for his work
in space exploration
and after he bought
10 million subscriptions
to "Time" magazine.
[ Laughter ]
I'm kidding.
Although it was a little strange
that everyone at "Time"
drove into work today
in a brand-new Tesla.
[ Laughter ]
Being named Person of the Year
is a big deal.
It's basically
Sexiest Man Alive,
but you're competing against
the Dalai Lama and the Pope.
[ Laughter ]
It was actually
a pretty competitive year.
The other finalists
were the scientists
behind the COVID vaccine
and the lawyer who appeared
at a Zoom trial
with a cat filter.
-Can you hear me, Judge?
I'm here live.
I'm not -- I'm not a cat.
[ Laughter ]
-Some news from Washington.
Today, President Biden signed
an executive order aimed at
improving customer experience
for government services,
like renewing passports
and filing taxes.
Yeah, now when you get audited,
the IRS agent
draws a little smiley face
on your return.
[ Laughter ]
And this is nice.
Now, when you're on hold
for two hours,
instead of light jazz,
they play even lighter jazz.
[ Laughter ]
Hey, I saw that former
Vice President Mike Pence
has been touring key election
states, like New Hampshire.
A lot of people think
that he could be gearing up
for a presidential run in 2024.
He's even been testing out
some campaign slogans
to see what people respond to.
Check some of these out.
First up, there's "Pence 2024 --
I make Mitt Romney
look like Post Malone."
[ Laughter ]
Next, there's "Pence 2024 --
I call ketchup hot sauce."
[ Laughter ]
And, finally,
there's "Pence 2024 --
One time, I heard
a Megan Thee Stallion song
and fainted."
[ Laughter ]
I think that's the one.
-Wow, yeah! That's the one.
-"Mother!"
-Oh, I heard that,
in a new documentary,
Russian President Vladimir Putin
revealed that, back in the '90s,
he worked as a cab driver
to make ends meet.
Yep, it was the only cab
where you got in,
and the driver told you
where you're going.
[ Laughter ]
"We're taking detour."
[ Light laughter ]
It was the last time Putin
drove a car
where the "passenger"
wasn't in the trunk.
[ Laughter, scattered groans ]
Hey, this is cool --
[ Laughter ]
-Wow!
-Listen to this.
New FDA-approved eye drops
just hit the market
that provide better vision
for up to 10 hours.
And they could replace
reading glasses
for millions of Americans.
Yeah, which means your dad
will now walk around
looking for the eye drops that
are on the top of his head.
[ Laughter ]
"Where did I put --"
You know some guy's
gonna be like,
"I bet if I use the whole
bottle, I could see Mars."
[ Laughter ]
Now when you notice someone
putting in eye drops,
you can play the fun new game,
"Reader or Stoner?"
It's cool. It's fun.
[ Laughter ]
Well, get this --
authorities in New Zealand
are investigating after one man
apparently got
10 COVID vaccine shots
on the same day
and pretended to be
a different person each time.
[ Laughter ]
If you asked what he got,
he says, "Johnson and Johnson
and Johnson and Johnson
and Johnson and Johnson."
[ Laughter ]
It was weird at his office
holiday party when he was like,
"So, how did you guys
feel after the ninth dose?
That one kind of got me."
[ Laughter ]
You guys hear about this?
A Michigan woman is currently
facing up to nine years
in prison
after she went to a fake website
called "Rent-A-Hitman"
and offered $5,000 to have
her ex-husband killed.
Yeah, you could tell
she was nervous.
Today, she logged into
Bribe-A-Judge.org.
[ Laughter ]
And, finally, a man in Texas
has been getting some attention
for his Christmas light display.
Check this out.
♪ Let me see you do it ♪
♪ Ay ♪
Hey!
♪ Snap your fingers ♪
♪ And then rock with it ♪
♪ Do it, do it, do it, do it,
gon' drop with it ♪
[ Laughter ]
[ Cheers and applause ]
-Wow.
I was expecting
an announcer to be like,
"And starting at point guard,
6'2", from Bethlehem..."
[ Laughter ]
At 10:00 p.m., the neighbors
asked him to turn it off,
and he was nice enough to say --
-"Okay!"
-There you go.
Guys, we have
exactly five shows left
before we go on Christmas break,
which means it's time
for that beloved
"Tonight Show" tradition.
It's time for
12 Days of Christmas Sweaters.
Here we go.
[ Cheers and applause ]
-♪ 12 days
of Christmas sweaters ♪
♪ 9 days left ♪
[ Cheers and applause ]
-That's right. Every show
between now and Christmas,
we'll be giving
one lucky audience member
a mind-blowing Christmas sweater
from the
Countdown to Christmas Cabinet.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Now, since there
are five shows left,
let's open door number 5.
[ Drum roll ]
Oh, it's a big --
That's a tall one.
You got it, bud?
-[ Grunts ]
-Ooh.
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪
Whoa.
That is something else there.
Look at that.
Wow. Let's see
the back of that guy.
It's like a -- It's a like
joker, type of jester.
It's got frills on the sleeves.
This is a great one.
This is a one-of-a-kind --
one-of-a-kind sweater.
Let's see who's gonna go home
with tonight's sweater.
Everyone look
at your seat number.
If I call your number,
come on down.
Who wants this sweater?
This is a good one.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Quest, can I get
a drum roll, please?
[ Drum roll ]
417!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Yes!
Come on down!
Come over here!
♪♪
Hey!
-Oh, my God.
-How are you?
-Great. Oh, my God.
-What is your name,
and where are you from?
-Anthony.
I'm from Austin, Texas.
-Yes!
We love Austin.
We love Austin, Texas!
This will fit right in
in Austin.
-Oh, yeah.
I'll blend in.
Yeah, I'll wear this to
the barbecue joints, yeah.
-Yes, you have to.
Would you like to try it on?
-Uh, yeah.
-What do you think, audience?
You want to see him?
Yeah, there's --
[ Cheers and applause ]
-I might need an assist.
-I'll help you.
-Yeah, I don't know if there's
a front or back.
-Is there?
-There's no real right way
to wear it, no.
It's kind of a reversible.
[ Laughter ]
Wow.
I mean, that's fantastic.
Wow!
[ Cheers and applause ]
Oh, my gosh.
That looks awesome!
That looks so cool.
You already got a strut
to your step.
I mean, this is fantastic.
All right.
Well, take that back to Austin
with you and enjoy.
-Thank you.
-Congratulations.
Give another round of applause
for our winner.
[ Cheers and applause ]
Stick around!
We're talking
with Dakota Johnson
when we come back!
Everybody, come on back!
[ Cheers and applause ]
♪♪